on va parler d'un tout autre sujet à
présent selon une enquête récente de
l'entreprise drivalia 45% des Français
souhaitent réduire l'utilisation de leur
véhicule notamment pour se tourner vers
des mobilités des mobilités plus douces
aux clés sous bois on va fêter une
nouvelle fois ces modes de déplacements
la fête des mobilités se déroule ce
samedi 13 mai c'est de 10h30 à 17h30
dans la cour de l'école Henri prou de
nombreuses animations sont au programme
on en parle avec Jean-Christophe Thuel
conseiller municipal délégué aux
mobilité douce aux Clayes-sous-Bois
alors Jean-Christophe Sual quelles sont
les objectifs de cette fête des
mobilités
alors l'objectif principal c'est de
sensibiliser les personnes au mode de
déplacement durable donc mobilité douce
d'une manière ludique et conviviale
voilà donc
comme j'ai dit alors il y a différents
partenaires et autour de ces partenaires
il y aura des il y aura des activités et
donc qui vont tourner autour de la
sécurité de la construction avec des
pushkars et il y aura aussi une partie
ludique justement
j'ai lancé le mot pour pouvoir attendre
la question en fait
alors le pouchka c'est c'est quelque
chose qui me tient à cœur en fait c'est
c'est un moyen de mobilité mais ludique
c'est pas voilà c'est c'est on s'amuse
avec mais je pense qu'on apprend
beaucoup avec on apprend beaucoup dans
la construction et je pense que
dans je vais faire un parallèle entre
l'écriture et la lecture quand on
apprend à quand on apprend à écrire
après ça nous ouvre des portes
dans la vie et construire quelque chose
de ses mains avec sa famille avec des
amis ça nous ouvre des portes sur le
futur et donc c'est pour ça que cette
année en a mis en place une course de
Pushka
voilà c'est
le même principe que les caisses à savon
parce que la caisse à savon a des à des
contraintes de freinage parce que faut
bien il faut bien qu'elle s'arrête et
nous on a remplacé la gravité par par
quelqu'un qui pousse d'accord tout
simplement voilà et ça
la sécurité grâce à la MGEN la fondation
de la route qui vont expliquer un petit
peu en fait les règles de sécurité pour
les jeunes et des moins jeunes le casque
les catabiops l'éclairage il y aura un
circuit justement d'initiation entre
un carrefour en feu rouge le stop ce
qu'on faisait à une époque quand je sais
pas c'est si vous avez commis ça mais
moi j'ai connu ça donc il y a quelques
temps dans les cours
et donc là voilà on le remet en oeuvre
donc ça prend pas mal de choses
il y aura aussi les vélos rigolos
donc les vélos rigolos c'est comme son
indique c'est pour apprendre c'est pour
parce que le vélo c'est c'est faut pas
que ce soit une contrainte il faut que
ça soit aussi un plaisir et dans les
vélos rigolos il y a il y a donc il y a
un partenaire qui a qui a récolté tous
les vélos qui trou les plus bizarres
possibles et qui les mettent à
disposition et on peut les essayer donc
en fait par exemple alors il y a le
grand bi donc moi je suis fan du grand
pays déjà après il y a des vélos où
lorsqu'on le guidon à droite et le vélo
va à gauche donc je vous défie de faire
plus de 2 mètres
après il y a plein de vélos mais je peux
pas diminuer comme ça il y en a plein
voilà donc il est il les invente il les
fabrique il les récupère dans des fois
et il aimait voilà il est loups et c'est
on passe un très bon moment ensemble
donc en fait il y a donc il y a tout ce
qui est mobilité il y a aussi des edpm
je sais pas si vous connaissez engin de
déplacement personnel motorisé qui vont
nous faire une petite démonstration en
fait les edpm englobe les vélos
électriques
motorisé donc tout ce qui était avant
musculaire est devenu motorisé entre les
trottinettes les vélos et il y a des
nouveaux engins les gyropodes je sais
pas si vous connaissez voilà des espèces
de skate qui avancent
électrique
et donc en fait donc comme toute
nouveauté on il y a des gens qui
expliquent qui exploitent
au fond c'est une nouvelle technologie
et ils vont nous faire une petite
démonstration de polo will donc en fait
Paulo c'est le cheval avec et ben on a
remplacé cheval par la Giro le gyropode
et il va y avoir aussi une petite jeune
femme qui s'est mise à faire de la danse
sur une roue donc voilà donc on exploite
on explore un petit peu tout ça
qu'est-ce qui va y avoir c'est important
pour la ville des Clayes-sous-Bois de
faire cette fête des mobilités alors
comme je vous l'ai dit c'est je pense
qu'il faut il faut tenir au courant
des
comment s'appelle la mobilité évolue
mais à une vitesse grand V en fait donc
en fait depuis le covid ont rien on s'y
remet en question sur le mode de
déplacement sur sur la pollution sur
plein de choses et je pense que la
les gens sont en attente justement de
tester
passer un moment et de voir un petit peu
comment on va se déplacer comment on va
faire son marché
moi je connais des gens qui qui
n'utilisent plus leur vélo pour faire
les courses ils y vont carriole voilà
donc en fait il y a toute cette et je
pense que rien ne vaut une bonne journée
de convivialité pour discuter de tout ça
et de voir de toucher et de parler avec
ses passionnés là voilà donc
l'association qui va être là sera là
pour expliquer un petit peu déjà le mode
de fonctionnement et pourquoi pas faire
quelques petits baptêmes et on aura
aussi un
comment s'appelle qui dit vélo dit
réparation donc en fait on a on a mis en
place comment c'est de plus en plus en
vogue d'apprendre aux personnes à
réparer eux-mêmes un atelier
participatif donc justement on le
faisait dans la ville on se déplaçait
entre
l'association donc en fait on s'est
mutualisé entre plaisir en transition et
lcbt donc les clés se boit
les villes preux en transition et on a
ouvert un local il est pas encore vu
officiellement mais il est presque prêt
et donc en fait on aura un local où les
gens vont pouvoir venir apprendre à
réparer des vélos donc vous avez un vélo
on répare pas la place mais on explique
voilà donc c'est ça le plus important
c'est donc c'est je pense qu'on va créer
une émulation et après bénévoles vont
nous aider à réparer aussi et si on peut
c'est pour moi c'est important voilà et
bien merci Christophe tilleul d'avoir
accepté notre invitation donc si vous
êtes intéressé la fête des mobilités
c'est ce samedi 13 mai rendez-vous de
10h30 à 17h30 dans la cour de l'école
Henri